very now congratulations thank you
another important win but we were
mesmerized by this move A4 I'm pretty
sure that this is your opening
preparation how far did you I guess uh
you know the computer
liked this move
um but in general yeah like why does the
main ideas in this position is for white
to play on the queen side and
um you know black and either play A5
here or queen B4 and actually on Queen
before I kind of improvised because I
mean I knew there was this bishop E2 95
Knight D3 idea but I was like okay I
kind of want to start with King A1
because it's useful
um pretty much in every position and
that way there's like none of this like
Knight C4 Knight A3 business right it
really discourages that
um so that was me basically like
disagreeing with the computer and you
know trying my own thing but eventually
I went to the you know um Bishop YouTube
plan
and we had the feeling that uh
everything went to your
game it was a very clean game so your
opponent failed to find any counter play
yeah well of course during the game it
felt a lot more complicated like okay
the move F5 really surprised me because
it looks very anti-positional you know
but a few moves later than I was kind of
questioning that I was like oh okay
she's improving this light squared
Bishop maybe I somehow messed up I mean
I think her main idea in F5 is if I go
for example G5 I think she's going for
F4 yeah that's for example the nice
point of her move that she's going to be
improving the bishop if I take there's
Bishop F5
Bishop D3 and then uh you know take they
have to take with the rook and yeah at
least like rook hf8 and basically I have
a lot of weak pawns and uh so I didn't
want to go for that so it wasn't like so
simple for white to just take the dark
squares so I played 95.
um yeah she played Knight D7 Knight D3
here was like a really big thing for me
after Queen D6 because again I was
thinking should I go for G5 and allow
her to play H6 and basically for example
your age six let's say I go H4
uh let's say takes takes on G5 Rook H1
uh and and then basically like let's say
queen E7 right so this okay I see the
computer wants me to just give away the
G5 Pawn that wasn't so obvious because
basically on F4 Bishop G8 you know she
has some play against E3 and I uh wasn't
so sure about this position and that's
why I had a really long think I went for
um
for A5 yeah and and then I kind of
realized okay she wants to take on G4
play H5 it seems reasonable
we can uh go there and she took with a
knight yeah I'll tell you what I think
was my best move of the game of what's
coming up we liked it yeah Knight A4
like okay that's pretty standard this so
I she went for this and then I think
this Rook hg1 was like kind of important
um yeah like because I have some choices
I can take on G6 but I think this move
yeah no I mean it's funny because at
this point I was like oh my conception
has worked out right like I hadn't been
so sure but at this point I was like
this is really quite nice and after 94
white just has like a huge choice of how
to play
um you know A6 B6 and I'll just tell you
the other big line that I thought about
after A6 B6
I was thinking about F3 here
um with the idea like Knight G3
um yeah because Knight F2 doesn't work
and then okay I didn't I was looking at
E4
and I thought this was really good I
mean she kind of has to take play Knight
H5 I'm probably gonna win a pawn so it
was kind of like a question of choosing
yeah between this position and here I
was even gonna go like Bishop C2 and
then E5 you know and it was a question
of like choosing between this position
and the other one and it was quite
difficult choice because they're both
they're both good
but here you're yes
your opponent is completely deprived of
any Contour place so you converted I
have to say work dg1 yeah my technique
was not so bad here because at first I'm
just going to take the pawn but then I
realized like no I should not just make
automatic captures I think Yasser taught
me that one
have I done yeah
we discussed uh we discussed the fact
that maybe I should see some you know
kind of intermediate moves first and
yeah before like that whole thing worked
out quite a while so I mean it looks
like yeah my technique was it was all
right here yes and Irina
one question once again you know if you
wouldn't be a chess player yeah what job
would you choose yeah well I've always
enjoyed writing so that's one
possibility
um and when I was little I had this idea
that I could also be a lawyer
you know because in general I like uh
arguing I like digging for the truth
um you know analytical thinking and yeah
I think uh I got that sort of pit bull
style you know that would work for for
law
thank you very much Irina and
congratulations once again thank you
absolutely our congratulations as well
Arena I mean bouncing back after a very
very tough loss that she did
hat tip just